otra prueba de misiles de corea del
norte la quinta desde el 11 de
septiembre con dos misiles balísticos
que terminaron en el mar de japón con
gran poder y el lanzamiento de misiles
por parte de corea del norte es una
violación de las resoluciones del
consejo de seguridad de naciones unidas
y condenó enérgicamente la acción acabo
de reunirme con el consejo de seguridad
nacional donde hemos recogido
información sobre los misiles y hemos
discutido nuevas medidas algo
las primeras investigaciones indican que
al menos uno de los misiles es un s lbm
de corto alcance un tipo de arma que el
gobierno norcoreano lleva tiempo
probando
y exchange y la situación actual en la
península se encuentra en un punto
crítico y todas las partes implicadas
deben centrarse en la situación general
actuar con moderación comprometerse a
mantener la paz y la estabilidad en la
península y seguir en la dirección
correcta del diálogo y la consulta el
régimen de corea del norte ha apostado
tradicionalmente por una fuerte
militarización con un programa nuclear
muy polémico en una marcha reciente del
ejército el país asiático presumió de la
cantidad de armas desarrolladas en los
últimos cinco años entre ellas lo que si
sospecha es un misil hipersónico
mientras desde eeuu siguen abiertos a
retomar las conversaciones diplomáticas
sobre el plan nuclear de corea del norte
estancadas desde 2019